c'est que la mort a cassé quelque chose
et après il faut il faut il faut
retrouver quelque chose d'autre comment
continuer le rêve avec quelqu'un qui est
mort
alors je vais à danois c'est un petit
village je me remets depuis ton client
puisque je remplace
le prêtre au curé la paroisse qui est
malade qui est pas en bonne santé en
bonne forme ce qui fait je le remplace
quasiment plus le bébé
on y va c'est bon
si vous êtes dehors vous pouvez dire au
gendarmes qui sont par là qui va vous
faire un PV ici parce que je suis le
curé du coup là la voiture
comment ça va la jeunesse
[Musique]
on va essayer de passer tout doucement
voilà alors
Claude François sur le petit Jésus
ou peut-être peut-être peut-être à la
fin à la fin à la fin d'accord et puis
pour les sièges c'est ici
[Musique]
on va le mettre comme ça ça ira
voilà c'est bien comme ça
[Musique]
je viens pour que le monde soit sauvé ce
soir vous êtes venus nombreux de
Belgique d'Allemagne de France pour une
baisse aussi au cours duquel nous ferons
mémoire de Claude François qui est
décédé à 11 mars
20 ans déjà
messieurs dames bonjour
qui est une passion qui est à l'avoir
fou mais pour vous il n'y a pas
d'antagoniste entre le fait de célébrer
la messe de célébrer Dieu et de célébrer
un culte
il y aurait pu avoir confusion mais dès
le départ j'ai mis des choses au parfum
dès le départ j'ai dit nous sommes là
d'abord pour célébrer le troisième
planche de carême avec un message
biblique est très fort on le fait je ne
viens pas je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
le prêtre de Claude François qui aura un
culte à un être humain mort je suis le
pré de Jésus-Christ qui célèbre
l'Eucharistie pour les vivants et les
morts et en l'occurrence pour la messe
Dominica ce que vous vous avez
finalement ça a été un moment de bonheur
puisque l'église était pleine comme vous
dites à craquer pour un prêtre
normalement c'est un moment inoubliable
c'est un moment de bonheur oui parce que
je pense que tout prêt rêve d'avoir son
église pleine donc ça au moment de
bonheur mais en même temps il faut pas
s'affoler
sinon on risque de devenir si on risque
d'être nous le gourou de la faire et ne
sont pas un goût les différences je suis
pas le groupe de Claude François je suis
pas son serviteur Claude François vous
connaissez oui c'était ma génération
parce que je suis dans 5 ans donc j'ai
48 ans
[Musique]
par exemple le téléphone pleure pour les
classiques voilà les classiques mais ce
qui m'a frappé moi j'étais pas fan de
Claude François mais j'aimais bien chez
les enfants parce que je trouvais qu'il
y avait il y avait quelque chose de très
humain c'est à dire très en santé un
homme qui a traversé
sa vie ou exalter sa vie et je crois que
c'est un message qui correspond à notre
société il est mort il y a 20 ans et 20
ans après pardon le téléphone le
téléphone pleure
quelle est la société où il y a pas de
divorcer il y a pas de séparation il y a
pas des enfants qui sont qui vivent ce
drame là donc je vois beaucoup de gens
sont reconnus là-dedans je crois il me
semble c'est ce qui explique pour vous
qui se cultes qu'il a qu'il a généré
engendré je crois que je crois que c'est
quand on touche le cœur des êtres
humains peu importe comment mais quand
on le touche dans la réalité des de la
vie les gens sont sensibles à ça ce qui
est très surprenant maintenant tout ce
que j'ai entendu c'est qu'il y a en même
temps les gens parlent d'un rêve qui se
poursuit à travers à travers Claude
François c'est l'évasion c'est celui qui
a réussi et en même temps ils ont fait
l'expérience pour beaucoup d'entre eux
de la mort alors ça c'est c'est très
surprenant vous le comprenez
c'est un réveil il sort du rêve et puis
ils arrivent au cauchemars
de leurs proches
et pourquoi on se connaît alors qu'avec
la musique on vit pas on vit que par
image on vit avec une distance on la
voit au loin sur une scène elle n'est
pas continuer la vedette
c'est que la mort a cassé quelque chose
et après il faut il faut il faut
retrouver quelque chose d'autre comment
continuer le rêve avec quelqu'un qui est
mort
on se nourrissant de ce culte là
et en même temps ça maintient la
communauté alors que tous les potes qui
sont mis là très peu connaissaient entre
eux donc ça continuera toujours ça
existera toujours ce phénomène de femme
je crois que l'homme a besoin de ça
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]